cette journée de manifestation avec vous
j'ai le casanova vous êtes expert en
stratégie et communication
alors déjà que le pass à sanitaire
passait très mal la transformation en
passe vaccinale est toujours compliqué à
à comprendre pour les manifestants qui
vont se mobiliser donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à un regain
justement du mouvement
syndical à 103,20
ce n'est pas certain dans la mesure où
il n'ya pas correspondance entre
l'émotion dans la société et la
participation à ces manifestations
pour une raison simple c'est que nous
avions auparavant des présidents et des
premiers ministres qui étaient issus de
grands partis politiques donc des
parties dans lesquelles les élus locaux
régionaux départementaux
voyaient leur avenir personnel en tant
que notable lié au succès ou à
l'insuccès du gouvernement et du
président
aujourd'hui nous avons un président dont
le parti fait 2,2 aux élections
municipales
3,5 aux élections régionales c'est à
dire qu'il n'a absolument aucune forme
partidaire pour lui faire savoir
peser sur lui dans un sens ou dans un
autre donc l'expression de la du
mécontentement populaire
cela fait un certain nombre de mois et
d'années que chacun sait que c'est sans
effet puisque ces députés qui n'ont
aucun ancrage en général et ne
connaissent ni leur circonscription
ni leurs électeurs l'ont parfois
théorisée comme monsieur bonnel qui dit
que ce sont des imbéciles et qu'il va
pas discuter avec des imbéciles qui sont
ses électeurs donc il n'y a aucune façon
de peser sur le président sur l'exécutif
à travers des manifestations
donc ces manifestations il faut les
regarder avec une grid nice qui est
plutôt celle avec laquelle on pouvait
regarder les manifestations contre
l'intervention américaine au vietnam il
ya 50 ans les parisiens les lyonnais les
montpelliérains qui participaient à ces
manifestations de rue savait
parfaitement que le président des états
unis était insensible au nombre de
manifestants à montpellier mais qui le
faisait parce qu'ils avaient le
sentiment que il voulait le faire
c'était un devoir à leurs yeux de le
faire mais l'utilité n'était pas au
rendez vous du coup l'arbitrage entre la
participation à cette manifestation et
d'autres activités
conduisait à certains moments ces
manifestations à être fort nombreuses
mais à partir du moment où elles se
répétaient à l'être beaucoup moins on
est exactement dans le même cas de
figure c'est à dire que la première
manifestation contre le pass sanitaire
rassemble une certaine quantité de
population qui sait qu'elle n'aura pas
d'influencé sur le président nil sur les
haies les parlementaires et puis ensuite
ça diminue à chaque fois c'est la
logique casanova
sur cette journée particulière sont
quand même les noms l'impact des propos
récents des vannelles macron à l'égard
des non vaccinés puisqu'il a dit
qu'il avait qu'il allait continuer à
emmerder les non-vaccinés c'est dans une
interview
là c'est quand même un contexte assez
particulier
ces propos vont certainement être dans
tous les esprits lorsque les
manifestants vont battre le pavé
aujourd'hui
68 % de français désapprouvent ses
propos vous ne les trouverez pas dans
les rues pour autant il y à un degré de
violence dont la société qui est accrue
par ce type de propos venant des sommets
de l'état ce degré de violence on peut
penser que le candidat macron souhaite
que ça se traduise par un vote aux
extrêmes qui lui évite d'être confronté
à madame pécresse mais ce que peut être
ils ne voient pas c'est que cela pousse
aux extrêmes la société au sens où cela
peut conduire à des comportements
extrêmes alors bien sûr il peut miser
dessus pour apparaître comme l'homme de
l'ordre si vingt trente ou cinquante
permanence de ses députés brûle mais le
problème n'est pas que ça produisent des
cortèges plus nombreux mais ça produit
une une violence des sentiments dans la
population pour ceux qui ne partagent
pas ses engagements ou le soutien à sa
personne puisque c'est pas son parti
c'est sa personne sa sas a produit une
tension extrême qui peut ne pas se
traduire par des manifestations de rue
nombreuses qui peut en revanche se
avec des éléments de violence
du bus table alors si on vous suit bien
finalement la pression aller du côté de
la rue aujourd'hui parce que s'il ya des
violences si ces manifestations elles
dégénèrent en heure entre les mains des
contestataires et les forces de l'autre
ça peut servir finalement le président
de la république la communication ce
n'est pas aussi simple
on a vu lors des plus grandes
manifestations des gilet jaune là où il
y a eu de grande violence qui ne
provenaient pas toujours clairement des
gilet jaune mais de groupes organisés
dont on ne sait pas très bien quelles
étaient les intentions mais qui n'était
pas sur les ronds points on a vu à ce
moment là qu'on montait jusqu'à 38 % de
français qui disait comprendre la
violence dans un pays démocratique on
n'arrive jamais à ces chiffres-là la
compréhension de la violence a atteint
des proportions qui dépassent
l'habituel et qui dépasse le taux nabeul
sur une longue distance pour une
démocratie il faut avoir en tête que 63
à 65 % des français souhaitent
qu'emmanuel macron ne se représente pas
mais emmanuel macron il n'a besoin que
de 20 à 22% de vote au premier tour
pourrait être opposé au second tour à
candidat ou une candidate
extrême donc la stratégie
conçue depuis des mois par emmanuel
macron et les équipes qui sont autour de
lui est une stratégie de pousser à
l'extrême le but n'est pas qu'il y ait
beaucoup de gens dans les rues mais que
ce soit violent le but n'est pas d'avoir
des oppositions très éclatée mais
qu'aucune opposition
présenté comme démocratique par un
système médiatique sur lequel il a
beaucoup d'influx ans ne puisse se
trouver face à lui mais au second tour
c'est un système qui est un système
construit pour garder la présidence
alors on peut s'interroger est-ce qu'il
est construit pour que la france aille
mieux bien sûr quand le président de
tous les français ce qui est la règle de
la vème république dit qu'il est là pour
emmerder jusqu'au bout dix pour cent des
citoyens et qui n'ont pas titre à avoir
leurs droits civiques on est sorti de la
vème république
merci à vous j'ai le casanova pour cette
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes expert
en stratégie et communication